ではよろしくお願いします
やわじいワンピチェバロパンディタンパイルパーセティネソーダンマンヴィジャナーティダッビースーパーラサンヤタという偈文の説明になります
六十四番 ヤーワジーワンピチェバーローパンディタンパイルパーセティネソーダンマンヴィジャナーティダッビースーパーラサンヤタ
とても簡単な偈だと思います
ヤーワジーワンピっていうのは生涯ということで
死ぬまで ピートチート除いておいて
バーローっていうのは無知な人
愚か者ですね 次の単語はパンディタンっていうのは賢者のことですね
賢者 知恵のある人 頭のいい人
パイルパーセティっていうのは付き合っているというかね
賢者の人 賢者と知恵のある人と一緒に生活しているということはパイルパーセティっていうことなんですね
お話をしたり 話を聞いたりという
仲良くしていることですね
それで 生涯無知な人が知恵のある人と仲良くしていてもというところですね
ピートチート入っているの
単語の二番目と三番目の単語は
その そういう関係を語ってるんで
ヤーワジーワンピと読むんですね
というのは 死ぬまででもというね
死ぬまでそこまでやってもという強調の単語なんですね
チェっていうのは またこのコンディションの条件を表す単語で
それで無知な人 頭の悪い人は
生涯死ぬまで頭のいい賢者と一緒に生活していても
ネソーダンマンヴィジャナーティ
彼が真理 事実は知らないんだよと
無知な人は生涯死ぬまで頭の人と一緒に生活したっても
どうったことないんだと
もう真理知るわけじゃありませんと
それもっと分かりやすくするんですね
次のたとえ話 たとえがありまして
最後のセクション ダッビースーパーサンガヤタ
あのスープとか一汁とかね
カレーとかなんとか作る場合は
あの匙でそれをかき混ぜてるんですね
それでおいしい料理作ってるとか
匙でこれをずっとかき混ぜたりかき混ぜたりする
しかし その食べ物の味は
匙は知りませんよと どんな味かと
だから料理の中にあるスプーンのように
スプーンが味はわかりません
と言えばよくわかると思いますね
面白いことというのは
料理作る場合は初めからスプーンが匙を使ってますよ
ちょこっと油で炒めようと思えば
またその匙でやっていて
で スープ入れましょうと言ったっても
それまた匙でかき混ぜたりして
煮出して料理終わるまで匙があの中に入り込んでいるんです
食べる時も匙で取って食べていて
それで最後に洗う時は匙と一緒にもう鍋を洗うと
だからずっと一緒にいるんですね
ご飯と食べ物と一緒にスプーンがいるんだけど
スプーンは全く何の味もわからないんだと
それはたとえ話で それもわからないんだったらね
立派なことなんですけど
それで頭のいい人と一緒にいるんだからって頭よくなるわけじゃないんだぞっていうことなんです
それだけの意味なんです
格好つけたっても 頭が悪いんだったらもう諦めなさいっていうことなんです
頭悪くたって私は一番気に入らないのは無知自慢することなんですね
もし私をいきなりサジって知ってます？って言ったらするでしょう
知りませんと それすごく自慢げに言うんです
知らないんだと だからそれだったらなおさら悪いんですよ
で 結構試しに私もいろいろ質問したりしますけどね
もう本当によく知ってること聞いてるんです
それは知りませんと 聞いたことがないんだと
で まあただ何か用事があって
私は無駄話はほとんどしないんだから
一応用事があって聞くんですけど
役に立たなくなっちゃうんですね
とにかくそれはなおさら悪いんですよ
知らないことを自慢げにするならばね
自慢にするならばね 知らないということは自慢になることじゃなくてね
やっぱり 知るように勉強しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
まあそれはそういうことでも
お釈迦様の住んでいるところで
ずっとどこにでも必ずあるお坊さんがいてね
まあいつでも誰が来ると前にさっさと出て行くんです
あーどうもどうそうどうそうとかね
他のお坊さんたちにも喋ったり
もう何も立場がない いつでもこの人前にいて
どちらから来たんでしょうか？と
あれやこれやとかなんでもかんでも
阿羅漢たちが自分のことで後ろにただじっといているんですね
教えなくちゃいけないし
瞑想する人に瞑想を指示しなくちゃいけないし
これで玄関で待ち構えているわけにはいきませんだからね
そこでかなり遠くからお坊さんたちがすごい遠くから来て
もう知らない世界 もうお釈迦様最上でっていうのはものすごい大都会だからね
すごい田舎から来て なんか知らないし
怯えちゃって なんとかな不安でね
それはまあ胸を張って
どうそうどうそう どちらからでしょうかとかね
って言ったら もしかするとこのお釈迦様の管理監督全部やっているマネージングやっているすごい方でしょうと
これはあれだ これはこちらでよくやっていて
一応遠くから来たんだからね
お釈迦様にすぐ会うことはしませんし
お寺にも慣れて 環境にも慣れて
瞑想もして それでお釈迦様があんた方はどこから来たんでしょうか？と聞くまでは待ってるんです
だからずっとお坊さんたちとやら
在家の方々やら 説法聞いて
何のことなくそちらにいて座って説法を聞いたりして
そこでお釈迦様があんた方はあまり顔を見たことがないんで
どこから来たんでしょうか？と話したら
そこでお釈迦様と会話できるチャンスなんです
その時聞きたいことを聞いたり
質問したりはする で なんか性格違いんですね
皆様は質問ありますか？と言ったら絶対聞かないでしょう
ムンド人がそうじゃなくて
そう言うと待ち構えているんで
自分にチャンスが来るまでじっと待ってる
何も知らないような感じで
どこからですか？と言ったら
すぐこういうこういう人で
こういうことで来て 実はこういうことを知りたいんだよと
さっさとその人が言うんです
それでこのお坊様たちは
この人よく知ってるんでしょうと言って
いろいろ聞いたんですね
ブッダの教えはちょっとわかりやすく理解できるように
四聖諦のことをちょっと説明してくれませんか？とかね
五蘊についてちょっとわからないんですけど
なんか遠くから遠く遠く田舎にいるんだから
ブッダの話を聞いたことはない
もう人から人から人から聞いてるものだからね
でお釈迦様に会って質問する前に
ちょっともう自分の知識を改めたいんですね
そしたら五蘊って聞いたことないねとこの人言うんです
四聖諦？別に何ですかね
そんな聞いたことないんだ
お坊さんがすごくびっくりしちゃって
このお寺のもうもうチーフマネージャーで
でも何でもない ただの侍事なんですけどね
振り回っているんですけど
何も知らないと どういうことかと
お坊さん お釈迦様にはっきりこれ聞いたんです
お釈迦様もずっとお釈迦様と一緒に生活してるんですけど
あの人はね なんで仏教のこと一欠片もわからないんですかと
お釈迦様にしてみたっても
これはちょっと立場がないでしょう
そう言われると その時なんですよ
お釈迦様が言ったのはね
あのね 愚か者っていうのはね
死ぬまで一緒にいても何も勉強しませんよと
砂じと同じだよと スープの中にある
ということを聞いたら
あ これはもうお互い出家と全然関係ない
もうただのもう出家してご飯食べてる人やったよ
それであのお坊さん すぐ分かりましたからね
まあそれだけの出来事なんですけど
それぐらいだったらね
なんでこれ記録して残さなくちゃいけないんですかというとね
それ大事なポイントを言ってますよ
あの昨日はそれくらいは説明しましたけどね
かなり明確に この七つのね
すごい聖なる宝物ありまして
その七つの一つはこの学ぶことなんです
学ぶことっていうのは
パーリ語で スッタというんですね
スッタダナンという 学ぶという学ぶ学問に仏教で使う単語はスッタという単語で
スッタっていうのは聞くという意味なんです
だから人が愚か者か頭のいい人やってどうやって決めるんですかね
勉強できる人か勉強できない人か
どうやって決めるんですかね
世間ではそれ決める方法ないんでしょうね
ただあの 何て言いますか
点数 あんた点数ない これ点でしょう
あんた頭が悪いと それで決めちゃうでしょうね
それでは決められません
偏差値が高いんだから
この人すごく頭がいいんだよとかね
これはないんですよ 偏差値で点数制度で人の能力は測りません
それで人が頭いいか悪いかっていう決めるところはスッタということで話聞いてるかないかっていうことなんです
たったそれだけで 人の話聞くならばもう頭いいんです
話聞かないんだったらもう砂じです
カレーの中にあるスプーンです
それを言うことはないんです
ですから この聞くということがよく勉強した方がよろしいんですよ
なんで我々 例えばすごい頭が悪いんだと
あの子は本当に勉強できないんですっていうのは話聞かないんですね
蓋かけてるんですよ 心に
心というのはもともとすごくだらしなくて
何の成長もない すごくもう醜い
もうもう原始的なもんなんです
誰の心も いい悪いどころじゃないんです
全部人間の生命の心ではダメで
もともと何にも役に立たない
しかし 話聞くか聞かないでということで全部決まります
何一つも知らない ものすごいさっぱりもうゼロ
もう真っ白やっぱ頭で大馬鹿者であっても関係ないんです
人の話聞く人だったら
みるみるうちにザーッと成長していくんです
ものすごいスピードで
だからこの自分が鍵かけて蓋かけるんですよ
蓋というか 土でかぶっかぶるような感じで
いっぱい土を泥をかけてかけてかけて心を抑えておくんです
もともとも何の能力も力もない
育てたこともない 知恵もひとかけらもない
ものすごく汚れている
極限に弱い心 大量に土をかけて埋めておくと
もう成長はしない それで話聞くということがあったら
いきなりサーッと成長していくんです
悟るためには ブッダの言葉っていうのは
まあ二 三行聞いても悟りますよ
聞くならば 聞いてないならば
三千億劫学んでも 別に
仏教知ってることになりません
だから人の頭が良いか悪いかそこで決め決めますよ
だからこの偈は決してこのもう否定的に非難して言ってるわけじゃないんだ
大事なことを言ってますよ
だから聞くか聞かないかっていうことは
その個人の自由だからね
だからなんで人の話聞かないかっていうことは
それはもう知りませんね
それぞれ人にはいろいろ言い訳あるでしょうし
[背景音楽]日本の社会でもよくある現象なの
話は 話は聞きたくないと最初からもう
自分が結論判断出してますからと
あんた判断出すために何か調べたんですか？いえ
それは必要はないし 話
話も聞きませんと いつでもそういう態度でしょうし
それで世界一頭いいと
で それで世界の競争で負けると向こう側が悪いんだと
よくやってます だからもう何でしょうかね
まあいろんな言い訳があって
我々はこの話聞かないというふうなことにするんです
例えば私でも丁寧に喋ると一人も聞かないと思いますよ
全く社会常識壊して ものすごく侮辱しながら喋ってるんだから
聞かずにいられない環境が起こるんです
まあ怒鳴られた侮辱したことでも覚えなくちゃあかんだからね
そこで私はチャンス狙ってます
侮辱されている言葉 しっかりと石に彫るように覚えてるでしょうね
時々間違ってても同時に何か入ってくるでしょうというね
心理の方も でなきゃ完全に心を鍵かけておくんでしょうしね
例えばある人に 何のことなく心を開けてあげるし
ある人にはいかなる場合でも心は開いてあげないというね
人は個人個人的にいろんな理由でそういうふうに決めちゃうんですよ
日本の学校でね 英語を教えるためには資格はたった 1個なんです
皮膚が白いかないかって
あのあれ学歴見ないんです
皮膚が白くてもみんな英語を教えることはできません
これ厳しいんですよ イギリスでもアメリカでもね
英語っていうのは別な学問で
それをしっかり勉強して学んで免許をちゃんと取ってないと
それでアメリカ大学とかね
イギリス大学も同じで研究してみんな論文書くでしょ
発表させません 英語をチェックするプロが別にいるんです
誰が書いたっても アメリカ
アメリカ人が書いたっても
論文は別の人全部チェックするんです
だからその自分の言葉っていうのはそれぐらい一応大事にしてはいるんです
だから まあただ白人だからはい
どうぞお願いしますって言ってもね
これはうまくいかないんですよ
結果はうまくいってないでしょうね
で まあだからまあもうなぜかというと
なんで私はそれ言ってますかって
私はあることを知っていて
ものすごいもう抜群の資格ある人がいて
英語を教えるために イギリスでも大学でも英語literature文学それで教えてもいたんです
こっちだって断られたんです
学校で教師が なぜかというと
資格はちゃんとあるんですけど
残念ですと 白人じゃないんだから
自分たちの法律ではもうこれは申し訳ないんだと
だからって気を悪くしないでくださいと
あなたはしっかり英語の資格を教える資格を持って持っていることは見てますよ
いっぱいありますからね
その人から見ればね もうあんた気を悪くしないでください
あんたよく英語を知ってますよ
いい加減にしろと言いたいところでしょうね
あなた方に認めなくても大丈夫だと
そこであの その教える許可は下りなかったんです
まあそれってそんなもんです
人間っていうのは まあそれは分かりやすい
もう個人的な問題じゃないんだから
まあまあね どうでもいいんだことですけど
我々個人が個人にしても
そうやって何か何か何か理由つけて心に蓋をかけておくんですね
話聞かないっていうこと
ある人が私に言った 私は時々日本語間違えちゃいますからね
まずちゃんと日本語を勉強してくださいと
そこまでは私は話聞きませんよってことなんですね
逆に言えばもう外人だからちょこちょこと間違ったって
もう何やつ それはと 恥ずかしいです
ちょこっと言葉の発音微妙に間違って分かりませんね
それはというのは それですごいこと言ってるつもりなんですけど
これもう明らかな無知自慢でしょ
無知はいいんだけど それまた自慢するんだから
それってすごい鍵なんですよ
そういうことで ちっちゃな時からもうもう子供は頭がいいと悪いっていうのを区別することはできないんです
で この話聞く子か 話聞かない子ですかというところで
勉強できるかできないかっていうことはもう
時々子供はいつでもうるさくて
これ何あれ何と聞くんだけど
答えとしても聞いてないんですね
別なこと あれは何？とか
一生懸命なんでこれこうなっていて
なんでこれは何？と言ったら
あ それはですねと あのね
これは何 そういうことはもうダメですよ
分からなくても これはこう
へー あ そうかと それでいいんですよ
子供だから質問したって何でもわかるわけないでしょうに
でも話を聞いてはみたんだけど
わからない だから へー
あーそうということ それは頭悪いわけじゃないんです
まだまだ大丈夫 わからない
大丈夫ってことなんです
でも聞かない それはなくて
次のことを聞く場合はね
大体子供の場合はうるさくあれこれ質問する子っていうのは
一応頭開けているんですよ
頭開けているんだから
うるさいことうるさいこと
もう何でも 何何あれ何これ何ばっかしで
答えある場合もあるし
ない場合はほとんどでしょうし
だから付き合う大人は大変なんですけど
でもそれってのはものすごく可愛くて
ギリギリと勉強していくっていうことなんです
その中でも質問はするんだけど
もうそれは質問も半分でやめて別なことを聞く
子もいるんですね それでも質問したっていうことは
情報を入れたっていうことなんです
頭に 情報を入れたんだけど
何か分からない なんか何か鳥みたいな面白いものを見たんだけど
初めて見るんだからわからない
それで頭の中であれは何の鳥かと
一応データ入れたいんですよ
だからあれ鳥何？と聞くんです
何の鳥ですかと それでなんだらかんだらなんだらかんだら鳥と言ったってわかるわけないんですけどね
これはシベリアから来る渡り鳥で
何とか鳥です そこまではもう頭に入りません
えーということで終わりますけどね
それでも一応心はまあ
被害とは言えますよ それで面白いことっていうのは
その時屁なんですけど
他の誰かが見ると あんた知ってますかね
この鳥はって説明するんですよ
手で足で鼻で口で体全体使って
ということは勉強しているんだということなんです
だから心開くと 私は一つ経験ありまして
すごい小さな子供に 人類学研究する人々が結構調べて調べて
論文書いて読んで書いて読んで理解する
もう大量の年  二 三年ぐらいはかかりますよ
それぐらいの量のデータをきちっと人類学的に十五分ぐらいでたたいて見せたんです
子供なんですけど 何の遠慮もなく
しかし 私は十分データはしっかりとこちらで評価して
結論だけきちっとコンパクトに
こういうこれはこういうことで
それはこういうこういうわけでこうなってるんだ
これはこういうことで
こういうわけでこうなってるんだよと
だからそこで別の場所で
その子はもう大人たちと何か遊んでる時はもうあれこれ説明するんですね
みんな腰が抜けてびっくりするんで
どうやってここまで知ってるのかと
ですから 別に天才っていうわけでも何でもないです
その子はその瞬間であ
ドア開けてるなとわかったんです
この情報には だったら一人前の全部やってやるぞと
そういうことで この話聞く体制できたら
それまたいい先生に出会えばもう言うことはないんです
誰でもすぐ賢者になるんです
それで話を聞くチャンスがいると
その時に限って心閉める人はどうしましょうかと
教えてくれる人がない場合は
勉強したくてしたくてすごく悩んでいて
教えてもらうチャンス来た途端もう閉めると
あの瞑想会に来て 実は私は用事がありますけど
あれでどういうことかと
で 考えて考えて 何ヶ月かも考えて
本も読んで いろいろ でもやっと時間作って
じゃあ瞑想は学んでみようかなといったことなんですよ
そんな軽々とは来られません
だから人間って忙しいでしょうに
遠くから その上インターネットを見たり
本を読んだり いろいろまた自分でもいろんなことを探していて
これもやっぱりなんとか学ばなくちゃと
まず言うのは 実は用事がありますから
1時間 で行かなくちゃいけないと
それで終わりです けど
私はそれでその人は終わりに終了にするんです
で まあ死にかけてる人だったらちょっと何とか言いますけどね
用事って何？とかね 言ったらまあそれで終わりますよ
自分 それぐらいつまらないことなんです
聞いたところで いい まあ大丈夫
大丈夫って それ人に言えないくらいの
普通の人にはそれは聞きません
あ そうですか じゃあはい
その時帰ってくださいと
だからこのもう例えば私は 2時間喋っている場合でも
1時間で帰ろうと思ったら
もう 2時間の 1時間の話も頭に入らないんです
もう鍵かけてます 話じゃなくて
あと十分ですね あと十分かと
それだけしかないんだからね
だからもったいないのは誰ですか？と
それってそんなことでバカになっていいのかと
それは個人個人で考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
晩ご飯作らなくちゃとかね
ただそれだけのことに無知で生まれて無知で死ぬ
なぜならば晩ご飯作ることには作らなくちゃいけなくなったと
それで自慢できる話かと
それは  善悪はまるっきり知らなくて
人生って何なのか全くも知らないで
幸福っていうのはひとかけらも知らないで
病気のままで苦しみのままで生きていて
犬猫のごとく死んでしまう
死んでも不幸に生まれ変われる
なんであんたそんなにひどい目合ったかって
やっぱり万々作ったんだからねということ
その時聞けた 何を作ったんでしょうかと
それもラーメンと あのまたなんとかあれこれチンして
そんな程度です あ 昨日作ったものありましたから
それを温めて味噌汁ですねと
それに人生もダメにするんです
だから知恵は何より本物の宝物だとお釈迦様はおっしゃってますから
宝物っていうのは 7つしかないんだよ
1つはこの聞くことなんです
そこは蹴っ飛ばしちゃいますからね
宝物を そういうわけで
今日学んでほしいのは
この決して人間を捨てないでください
あの人頭悪い この人頭が悪いいいとかね
頭いい悪いということは
そう簡単に判断できるものじゃないんです
誰でも同じなんで頭の状況は
誰にも何か自慢できるものを持ってるわけじゃないんです
誰でも無知なんです しかし
同じ無知同士ですけど
話聞く人と聞かない人の差があまりにも大きいんです
話聞く人っていうのはもう瞬間で
だからお釈迦様がバールチリアバーヤというある邪教の人に立ったまんまで 1分もかからない
もう 1分もかからない
ほんのわずかなちょこっと言っただけで完全に悟り開いてしまったんです
話聞いたんです このサーリプッタ尊者っていうのは
お釈迦様の弟子から話仏法を聞いたんですよ
お釈迦様からじゃないんです
この弟子といっても  5人比丘の最初の弟子たちの 5人の一人
アッサジという大阿羅漢でしたけど
で あんた方の先生の教えはどういうものかといったら
アッサジ長老がそんなことを聞いても
私はあまりわかりませんと
本人悟ってはいるんですけどね
これということはわかりませんだけど
別に説明しなくてもどれ大丈夫ですから
ただおっしゃっていることは何やとちょこっとだけ教えてくださいと
そうすると覚えていたある偈一つ唱えたんで覚えていたんです
偈の 1行目終わるとサーリプッタ尊者が喜びに悟っているわけ
二行聞いたのは悟ってからなんです
すごい頭がいいでしょ
でもただ話聞くだけ 話は聞いてるんです
だから聞く力によって能力の差が出てくるんです
サーリプッタ尊者が聞いた偈っていうのはこの「イエダンマヘトゥッパバヴァーテーサンヘトゥンタターガトゥワーハ」
それ聞いたところでもう悟りに開いて悟り開いて 「
イエサンチャヨーニロードーエワンバーディマハサマナ」ってそれ後から聞いているんです
二 三秒で言う偈でしょ
節入れていったって入れていったってもまあ二十秒ぐらいです
どうだいと 話聞くことの力っていうのは
だから一行目見ればもう「物事は原因によって生まれるんであって
その釈尊がその原因を語っているんだよ」と 「
物事は原因によって生まれるものである」と
その原因を語っているんだ
それで悟れます だからこの聞く力なんですよ
まあそこまでは皆様期待しなくてもいいんです
だからサーリプッタ尊者の頭は「物事は」と言った途端
ちゃんと文字通りに「物事」というふうに頭に入るんです
皆さんの頭に入らないでしょ？「物事」って言ったら全然何も通じないでしょう
はっきり言えば 英語で言えばフェノーメナということなんです
私は「物事」代わりに「現象」という言葉を使ってましてね
それで私は 「ああ まあこの人は日本語あまりわかりませんだから
じゃあ聞かないことにしよう」ではないんで
ないんで 私もすっごく考えてその「現象」という単語を入れてますよ
それで仏教をなめた人々は 「
そんな訳間違ってるでしょ
ああ まあお坊さんだから勝手に訳す
それは学問的じゃないんだから
我々は学者の本を読もう」とか 「
それは『行』で訳しなくちゃいけないんではないか」とか
私は「『行』って何？知ってるの？」かと聞きたいんですけど
もうとっくに鍵 鍵じゃないんですよ
もうあの あの 原子爆弾から身を守るぐらいシェルターかけてるんですよ
この蓋の厚さは 原子爆弾落としても破れないという
これガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うのはただのあのあれ 「
私はしっかりと蓋かけてるんだぞ」っていう意味なんです
だから「物事は」って言ってもあまりわからないことを私は知って
私は「現象」という言葉を言うんですけど
でもその意味がわからないでしょ？結局は
これ哲学的な意味じゃない
単なる日本語なんです
もし心で「現象」って言えば
もうありとあらゆるものは何でもかんでも現象ではないかと
現象でないものって何一つないんだから
自分も現象でしょ 自分も心も何でもかんでも存在も宇宙も何でもかんでも現象でしょうに
現象は色々原因によって生まれるんであって
原因が壊れると潰れますよと
それは全部仏説そのものでしょ
だから悟らなかったっていうことはおかしいものであって
悟ったっていうことは一番普通なんです
それは今びっくりするエピソードとして伝えているんです
サーリプッタ尊者すっごいんだと
本当に言うならば それって当たり前なんです
話聞いてるんだからね
それ以上言うことないでしょうに
なのに何で他の人はね
それからみんなたくさんのお坊さんたちも
もうずっと伝統の中でその偈を伝えてきましたけど
誰もこの偈を聞いて悟ったっていうことは聞いたことはないんです
ということは聞いてないんだっていうことなんです
それで聞くということはね
すごいことですよ これどう説明すればいいかと私もあんまりできませんだけど
ただ耳で聞いてるっていう意味でもないんです
心はオープンしているんですよ
いわゆる受ける準備が
いわゆる受信機を調整しているんですよ
心は受信機なんですね
何もやるこ ちょこっとメーター合わせておけばいいでしょうに
それで電波が入るんです
まあテレビで見たら一応スイッチぐらい入れなさいよと
スイッチぐらい入れておくと
何の苦労しなくたっても
もういくらでも番組がもう見えるでしょうに
それやらないんですよ
人に文句を言うのはなんかすごい面白い番組だったと
みんなすごくびっくりしていますけど
あれ再放送もあるんですけど
そうですね やっぱりね
見たいですね 私もやっぱり知りたい
そればっかりいくらに考えたってね
だからスイッチ入れなさいよとテレビの
それで話終わりだと それで全部番組が流れますからね
それで知りたい 見たいとか泣かなくても
だからその心の 心が受信機に例えれば
やっぱり受信機のスイッチ電源を入れてほしいんです
他はそんなに気にすることじゃないんです
だから人間の頭悪いとか頭いいとかね
そんな話にならないことで聞いてるかないかという
たったそれだけ 聞いてるとわからないものっていうのは何一つもないんです
聞くならば 人間の心には
もう一応 俗世間の知識であるならば何でもできるはずなんです
そのスピードじゃなくて
もっとすっごいスピードでできるはずなんです
ただ聞いてないだけ だから聞いてないということは
本は読んでいるんだけど読んでない
ことにもなります 見てはいるんだけど
見てないという それで我々は蓋をかけて
受信機の電源は入れないということにします
心ですから いつでも電気が流れていますけど
これスイッチオフできませんからね
心の 機械だったらもうね
電源切ったりオンにしたりどちらでもできますけど
心っていうのはずっと輪廻転生していますから
機能しながらストップはしないんですよ
だから心の場合は何とか言い訳をつけてそこで遮断するんですね
[背景音楽]何でもいいんですよ
言い訳っていうことはね
大事なことでなくてもいいんです
例えばこんなこんな日本色は合わない
日本にとかね それだけでも話聞かないことにしますよ
この頃はね なんでこんな変な色ですね
それはとかね 日本の風土に合わない色ですねと
そうすると私は喋ってても風土に合わない色ですね
なんでこういう人々はね
ちょっと現代で肉体とか締めないんでしょうかねとか
そればっかり考えてるでしょ
そうすると こちらはすべてのものは無常やとかね
もう眼耳鼻舌身からもういろいろ心が汚れて悩んで悩み苦しみあるんだ
そう言ったら なんかこれは赤とかね
着物だったら寒いでもぐらいでも我慢できる
そればっかり頭の中に
もう聞いてないでしょ
そこで聞いてないことをすごくいい証拠あります
とってもいい話でしたと褒めるでしょ
あの時は聞いてないってことも確かなんです
聞いていたならば それじゃ腹が立ってるはずなんですけど
私は微妙に計算しながら喋ってるんだからね
心にどんな反応を起こすか
起きているかと知ってます
あ とってもいい話でしたわと言ったら
あ そうですか それはよかった
ありがとうございますと
もう早く逃げるしかない
聞いてないんです だからもう何とでもいいんですよ
もう人間にはもう無知でいるためには
大胆な理由はいりません
例えば 家が貧しくて勉強できなかったとかね
あるいは父親に逃げられて
母親が朝から晩まで仕事
バイトやってるだけでね
もう忙しいんだから子供に仕事をさせたとか
何とかとかね だから勉強できなかったとか
そんな理由でなくても大丈夫です
そういうふうな理由じゃないんですよ
本当にくだらないことで
聞かないんです だから聞くというたった一つの機能で
人間はこの上のない財産身につくんです
解脱するところまで 一切の苦しみを乗り越えるところまで
ただ聞くだけで成り立つんです
そこはやめさせるために
大乗仏教文化ではそれは舎門浄でしょうと言ったりするんです
舎門浄はすなわち清浄でしょうと
舎門じゃない 声聞ですね
声聞浄という声聞というのは聞く
何言ってるんでしょうかで
聞くなよって意味なんですよ
あれもすごく威張ってますよ
声聞浄は これは清浄で
我々は大乗仏教やと 自分言ってることの矛盾に全然もう何億年経っても気づかないんです
だから私はすごくなんか失礼に強烈に言わないと
私はこの相手 これもうこれ他力ですよ
こちらで爆弾を落として
あのシェルターを破るんですよ
やってはいけないんですよ
仏教では 自分がかけた鍵は自分で開けなくちゃいけないんです
それで外から鍵をこじ開けて壊すんだから
あまりいい気分にはならないんです
自分で開ければ鍵も壊れませんし
だからこの大胆なやり方でどこまででも進むということはないんです
私はすごい凶暴なやり方でやるのは一回だけですよ
いわゆるもう本人が破ろうとしないんだから
ちょこっと一発殴って
もう鍵がもう壊れるようにする
で それから本人がもう自分の意思で聞くことにしなくちゃ
もうそれ以上はできないんです
そういうことで この学ぶ世界っていうのはそういうことで
仏教は学ぶ世界なんですね
で 学びなさいと言っているのは
誰でもバカだからなんですよ
それで人を差別できませんよ
だから学びなさいというのです
学ぶためにはもう何もしなくていい
話聞きなさい というぐらいのものなんです
即席の翌世間の学問も同じことですよ
歴史であろうが 科学であろうが
生物学であろうが もう何でもどうってことないんですよ
すごくシンプルなんです
しかし 聞きなさいよ だから聞くということは大事であって
それ聞くということの説明はできないわけでもないんですけど
難しいんだけど それ説明したっても聞かないんだからどうしようかという
それで学ぶ程度にもいろいろランクあるでしょ
例えば 学校で子供たちはみんな一生懸命学ぶ
学ぶだけで試験出してみたら点数バラバラでしょう
あれは聞いた程度なんです
大体人間っていうのは倍率を
例えば喋るパワーが百にすると聞くところでこのもう二十とかね
三十ぐらいにレベルダウンするんですよ
これは現代 この放送の世界でよくわかりますよ
例えば普通のカメラで写真撮ると
例えば紙に印刷するような
すごく写真がいいんですよ
これデジタルになったでしょ？デジタルになると画質は結構落ちているんです
それはさらにさらに画質を落とすんです
放送する場合は大量にデータが行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこで明確な画像を送ると時間かかります
これ映画になりません
あれ高画質って言ってるでしょ
実は逆なんです あれは
そこでこのフォーマット
あのフォーマットとか画像処理フォーマットいっぱいありまして
皆様知っているのはコンピューター使ってますから JPEGフォーマットぐらいと思いますけど
放送では別なフォーマットを使っていて
この JPEG というフォーマットも画質を大量のデータだから
これすごく小さくするんですよ
小さくしちゃうと早く重くはないし
メールでも簡単に送れるし
例えば皆様の携帯に来る写真とコンピューターでインターネットでダウンロードする写真というのは随分違うでしょうね
だから携帯の強さに合わせてむちゃくちゃ画質を落とすんですよ
それでなんで落とすのか
それぐらいでわかるでしょう
何さんやというね あまり目でそれほど区別しませんよと
それ威張ってるのは人間見ても見てないんだからなんです
それよく知ってますよ
まあまあ なんとかもうそれなりにあれば大丈夫やと
そういうことで まあ例えば試しにこの放送局なんかに行って
その機材調べてみてください
放送局が放送するプロ用のビデオやらいろいろあるでしょ
そこから映像と音を聞いてみてください
えらい素晴らしいんですよ
びっくりするほどものすごい
なんだこれと それまた放送して空気に流れるでしょ
自分のテレビで見ると全く面白くないんです
で 画質は落ちてます それで NHK が NHK が100ぐらいの音質と画質で放送しても
我々 30ぐらいの倍の力で受信していますから
番組は見てはいるんだけど
やっぱりテレビ局にある機械ほどではないんですね
音も音楽も同じですよ
このスタジオでその時流せますよ
音楽は その時 すごいいい音楽だなと
俺 録画して放送で番組って何だこの面白くないと思っちゃうんですよ
かなり画質は落ちている
そこで高価なステレオをつけたりして画質をアップしようしたって
元はダメだからね それほど上がりません
だから現代機械的にでもそれ説明できますから
例えば先生が 100の力で教えても
子供が 2乗の力で聞いてるならば
子供の心に入るのは 20%なんですね
もう一人の子供は 30の力で聞いてるならば 30%が入っているんです
で ギリギリで 100%の力で聞いてると
まあ全部わかったことになります
だから試験では 100点満点以上は取れないんです
100点満点であなたは 200点だよっていうことは成り立たないんです
私は勉強している時は
これがどういうことかと挑戦してみたんです
なんで 100点満点でしょうかと
100点は 100点かもしれませんだけど
なんで 130点は出さないんでしょうかと
出せるはずですよと 論理的にはと
それ仏教は推薦しているのはそういう世界なんです
ということは 例えば先生は 100の力で語っていて
もし生徒が 300の力で聞いているとどうなるんでしょうかと
だからもともと聞く能力ないんだから
これわからないと思いますけどね
聞く能力っていうのは
自分でいくらでも倍率を上げます
上げられます 本当は 100もダメなんです
足らない のに 100の力で誰も聞いてないんです
それで私はこれで 100に 100点満点になんで基準は 100点だったら
なんで 300点ぐらい上げられないのかっていうことに挑戦して
ある日 授業中 なんとか別なテーマなんですけど
なんかある学者の話をちらっと先生は言ったんです
まああの人はこれはまあまあ具体的に言います
このインドで 経典ではね
このお釈迦様 インドであったこの邪教の哲学をね
こういうふうにまとめてますけど
まああれはただもう誰か仏教の編集者たちが考え
仏教的な考え方であって
実際歴史的にはまあそんな哲学はありえないと
なんとか先生言っちゃって
私に後ろ先生もまあまあなんとか何とかそう言ってますから
そういうことやと 私はすごくそれ違和感あったんです
聞いてるんです 私はもうより聞いてるんだからね
だからこの教授が誰かが言った
だからそれですよと決めた
それは学問的じゃない
あの教授がすごい有名な人もちゃんと調べて行ったかないかということを調べなくちゃいけない
と言って それについてそことレポート書いても出さなくちゃいかなかったし
で もう誰でも A4 の 2ページか 3ページのレポートですね
毎週ぐらい書きますからね
私はざっと調べて調べて調べていて
大体 46ページぐらい
と書いて じゃあみんな書けましたと言って
はいと それを上げたんです
分厚いレポート じゃあどうしますかと
あんたは という感じで
何のことは 2ページぐらいです
先生 私は一生これぐらい勉強してないんだよと
こういうテーマについて
それで先生一生懸命それを勉強して
みんなにこれ読みなさいと
結局はすぐにそれはテキストになりまして
だから私はもう 100点満点取りたくて出したものでしょう
だから私は何点取ったんでしょうかね
結局は まあ論理的には 100点中 100点満点だからね
100点 200と書けませんから
それはどうでもいいんだけど
実際は私は 100点満点の壁を破ってみせたんです
それって聞く能力なんです
鵜呑みにする能力じゃないんです
それ調子に乗ってもいろんなところでやっちゃったんだからね
結構一人の教授が大学辞めることになっちゃったんですけど
もうまあ客員で来たんだから別に問題なかったんですけど
私も悪いし 教授も悪かったんでしょうがないんですけど
教授もちょっと調子に乗っちゃったんです
で 同じ授業なんですけど
心理学系で でもうちょっとあなた方もね
調べた方がいいでしょうかなんとか言ったんですよ
切り替わったんでそれは
言うんじゃないよと 他のみんな怠けてるかもしれませんだけど
みんなに一般的に平等に言うんじゃないよと
調べる必要あるんじゃないかとか言った時
私はそうですね でもつまらないんだと
そういう程度の程度では
と なんでそういうことを言いますかと言ったら
私はもう仏教の心理学っていうのは
こういう風に こういう風に
こういう風に勉強するものであって
実際はこれこういうことを喋ってあって
こんな基準では何一つも把握できんやと
研究もできないんだと
そのやり方では ですから
真っ先に基本データはこれこれこれこれこれこれ取らなくちゃいけないんだと
そちらのもう 1万分のやってないんです
ただ何とか何とか喋ってそれで終わると思っていたんです
これですぐ まあさすが教授ですからね
まあ私にそう私はやってないんだから
どんなどういう風に始めたらよろしいかと私に聞いたんで
この勉強はと 言ったらだったら先生真っ先に
これこれこれと読んで
こういうこういうふうに
それからこういうこういうふうなことをやるんだよと言って
メモを書いて 参考文献書いて言っちゃっただけで
また戻ってこなかったんです
で 私は別にとったことはないんですけど
また 3人その研究クラスにいましたからね
3人にはどうしようもない
私は知ったことない 私はただ単にもう余計なことを言うなよという調子だけなの
余計なことで抗っただけ
で 何かすると黙っていたんです
で それはなんで なんで言いますかというと
この聞く力の問題なんですよ
だから聞く力によって知る力が上がったり下がったり
それは天才とかなんとかいうとこじゃない
どうったことはないんですよ
誰にでもできる これ鵜呑みにする人っていうのは 100 で聞いてるわけじゃないんですよ
あれは大体 10%  5%の聞き方に鵜呑みにする性格は
だって何も考えてないでしょ
それは聞いてないとほとんど等しいなんです
だから物事を鵜呑みにする人はもうほとんど聞いてない人と同じだと
鵜呑みにするのに別に知恵があるわけないでしょうに
人言うことそのまんまで
ものはかつて浅原さんがもうサリン作りなさいと言ったら
はい わかりました もう存じで作るんだから
それって頭いいわけじゃない
だから東大出た京大出たからといってね
全部そういうグループでしょ
だって普通の人にサリン作れるわけないでしょうに
かなりテクノロジー持ってないと
でも頭は悪いということは明確なんです
だからただ記録するだけではね
頭いいわけじゃないんです
言ってることは覚えていて
それでも鵜呑みにして
すごく頭いいんだったら
だったらこういう IC レコーダーはもっとすごいでしょう
昔テープレコーダーはでかかったんですけど
IC レコーダーって今っていうのはこの指親指 1本ぐらい小さいでしょうね
これ 2  3時間ちゃんと記録してくれるんだからすごいんですね
拝んだ方がいいんです
記録ぐらいはなんのことないんです
だから学ぶ方法は 昨日はちょこちょこっと若い方々を見ましたからね
一応学びやり方とかも言いましたけども
それは一応仏教の話よりはちょこちょこっと私の個人的ないろんな裏技いっぱいありますから
もう何でも 1発で覚えておくとかね
理解するとかね 教えた人よりもこちら知ってるんだぞとかね
で それをいろいろ裏技があるんで
それは裏技と言ったってなんのことない
この聞く力なんですよ
新しい情報やら新しい知識を私に教える人が教えて終わるまでは私はじっとしていますよ
終わったらはい これから私が喋りますよということになるんです
あなたは勉強しなさいと
なんでそうなるのかというと
向こうは誰でも 100 で喋ってます
これは 200 ぐらいで聞けばいいんです
200 で聞けばあれよりは倍知ってます
そういう場合は本も全部読まなくても大丈夫です
もうざっと見たらもうこういうことだと
これがポイントだということが見えてくるし
でまあ大体このすごく勉強できる人々はみんな大体同じことをやってます
ということで この聞くということですよ
結局は だから聞くということは結局どんなものでしょうかね
ただ耳で聴覚というわけじゃないんですよ
まあ一応別な経典ではありますからね
聞くということはどういうことかというね
で だから喋る人に対してまず信頼がなければダメなんですね
いわゆるこの人はこのデータ知っている
情報を知っている 伝えることもできるんだから
私は知らないんだから
この人を信頼して じゃあ聞こうではないかと
で そこは 第1簡単なことで信頼ができちゃうと集中するんで
心は そのまま人が言っていることをそのまま百で聞こえるんです
まあこの人は まあこの人はいくら日本がよくわからないんだぞと投げかけちゃうと
信頼性を失っています
で 聞けなくなるんです
ですから まあそれが必要です
それで聞く 聞きながら
これってどういうことか
これってどういうこと
これってどういうことかと
すっごい早くそれは処理しなくちゃいけないんです
なんでこうなるんでしょうか
ああ そういうことか なるほどとか感じで
データをずっと頭の中で処理するんです
処理して処理しながらパックする
そのまま覚えるんじゃないんです
私ってそれやるんです
人の話 講演とか聞く場合は
そのまま聞いてないんです
ずっとデータ処理をするんです
こうだから これこれでこう言ってる
全部聞いていながら ものすごい早くデータ処理をしているんです
それが人を信頼していないとできないんですよ
人を信頼するとカチッとそちらに釘付けてます
こうしながらこうしながら足を振りながらボールペンを指で回しながら
あれ聞いてない連中です
そんな余裕がないんです
頭に データ処理にはすっごく時間
すっごく忙しいんです
それでまあ話終わって
こちらがこれ大量にデータ処理しているんだから
自分の心に基本的な概念にきちっと腰を下ろしているんです
それでも入れたデータだから自分のものじゃないんです
それからお釈迦様のアッタンウパパリッカティということをやってくださいと
この入ったものはどういうものか
どんな因果法則で何でも因果法則だから
どんな因果法則で なんでそうなるんでしょうかということは
自分でまたさらにプロセッシングするんです
そうすると あの こういうことをこう言ったんだけど
それは違うんじゃないかとかね
出てくる こういうこと
こう言ったんだけど もっともっと違う違うもあるんではないかとか
そこのアッタンウパパリッカティと意味を観察するところでもうさらに増えていくんです
そこでこの 3番目の仕事をしたところで
初めて自分の知恵になるんです
教えたものじゃないんです
その場合は その過程でどんどん倍率を上げて上げていかなくちゃいけないんです
だから おっしゃったものよりたくさん学んだことになるんです
それは俗世間のこと それはできないのはブッダの話の場合にだけです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことをよりたくさん学ぶことはできないんです
私はどちらでも挑戦しているんだからね
俗世間の知識にも ブッダの
知識にも で 百で聞こえれば
もうもう世界一天才です
ブッダの話は ブッダの話以外は
もういくらでも聞いたものよりは三百倍理解することはできます
だから私は百点満点という理屈はあまり
気にしないんです まあそこをこの偈にしたっても
私はいくらでもみんな挑戦できますよ
世の中でこの偈を見て
じゃあ理解してみなさいと
何も出てこないと思いますよ
当たり前ね サジには味がわからない
そうか まあ愚か者にはできないかという
それで終わっちゃうとどうなるんでしょうかと
それはバカな人はただもう処分しているだけでしょう
見込みがありませんと
何の仏説でもなくなるんです
そういうことで 聞く機能はそんなもんなんです
だから私もすごいむちゃくちゃもう限りなく広げてみせるのも
そういう聞く能力のやり方ですよ
愚か者 まあ当たり前の話ですよね
バカな人はね 先生のところにお手伝いしたってもね
バカはバカですよと というぐらいの話でしょうかねと
ということで ちゃんとこの聞く能力というかね
だから聞く能力に合わせて人の知識の差が出てきます
最初からももうブッダの最初からではなくて
ブッダの話はすごく聞いておけば
俗世間の知識っていうのはすごくちょろいんだと感じますよ
なぜかというと それはすごい理由があるんです
ブッダの話は純然たる因果法則なんです
完璧な因果法則なんです
完璧な因果法則に法則を知っている人には
もう曖昧のなんとなくの因果法則の科学世界っていうのはそんなに難しいことじゃないんです
普通 科学世界は完璧にデータあって言っているわけじゃないんです
それなりにそこそこ研究して
そこそこデータを取って
そこそこ調べて それまた時間かかる
薬一つ決めるためにも
まあ五 六年かかるもんだからね
いろいろハンディがありますからね
世の中で ステムセルというステム細胞の研究にしたっても
昨日新聞ではなくて インターネットのニュースで見ると
もう教会がもう反対しているんだと
ステムセル研究する人々はみんなもう教会から破門するべきであると誰かが言っちゃって
どこまで世の中アホに溢れているのかとね
もうそうなってくると
ステムセル研究する人々にもスピードはものすごく遅くなっちゃうでしょうしね
そういう世界だから まあブッダの因果法則のことを知っているならばね
まあ簡単に勉強しようとすればできます
はい それでこの偈はそこら辺で終了になりますけど
一応人間は誰かさんと一緒にいるんだからといって
あの 何の意味もないんですよ
それで胸を張って私は世界一のノーベル賞を取った人の家にいるんだよと言っても
だから何？と 自分が誰かの家にも仕事に行って
毎日仕事に行くかもしれませんだけど
その誰かさんがノーベル賞まで取ってるんだぞとか言ったっても
この人にとってはそれって何の関係もないんだから
しかし 聞く耳を持ってるならば
ただあのハウスキーピングに行ったかもしれませんだけど
ハウスキーピングに行ったおばあさまかもしれませんだけど
この先生は例えば科学者でノーベル賞まで取っていて
もし聞く耳があれば頭が良くなりますよ
聞いてくれるんだったら
いくらノーベル賞を取ってる教授であろうとも
この家の掃除してくれるおばあさん聞く話に答えるんです
そこで相手がびっくりするんですよ
この人は 我々は大学研究でね
一生かけていて 何か暦あるみたいなとかね
それで何か言ってることは何かちょこちょここと分かってるみたいと分かると面白くなっちゃって
どんどんどんどん教えてあげるんですよ
どうせ専門的な世界だからね
掃除に来たおばあちゃんも
もうすごいノーベル賞ぐらい取った人のぐらい知識になるわけはないんだけど
かなり物知り屋にはなります
ですから まあ偉い人と一緒にいるなら
一緒にいるならば もう聞くという資格は必要なんです
ということで 仏教の世界は聞く耳持たない人々とは仲良くしないんです
意味がないんです 迷惑だけ
ずっと人と一緒にいる必要はないしね
もしお釈迦様のそばにずっと弟子たちが一緒にいなくちゃということになったら
お釈迦様はどんな思いになるでしょうかね
何 10万人とかね 出家するする人がそのままで
べったり磁石みたいな感じでついていたならば
それはなかったんです
話を聞いて 自分で実践して悟って
もうそれで でお釈迦様は全く自由で
もう何人か気に入ってるというかね
性格的にもう話通じる
気に入ってる何人かと一緒に次の村に行って
次の村に行くと そういうことで
時々一人でも行くと お釈迦様だけ一人で行って
ある時々村に行って 村の人々みんな仏教徒になっちゃって
でもお釈迦様また一人で帰るとお坊さんたちも知らない場合もあったんだからね
お坊さんたち一人もいない村なんですけど
みんな仏教徒でよくよく成長しているんだっていうケースもありましたからね
この四念処経を教えた
このカンマーサダンマという町というかね
国ですけどね あまりお坊さんたちが住んでいて
お寺が作ってすごい活動したっていう記録はそれほどないんです
もう瞑想に対しても もう真相たる教典はそちらでその人々に語ったんです
比丘たちでもないんです
一応比丘たちは読んでますけどね
その村を選んだんです
理由は一応注釈書に書いて
その村の人々はすごく頭が良くて
すごくサティの世界を分かっているんだと
常に実践していると それにもうこそこそとお釈迦様がいらっしゃって
教えたことはずっとそのまま実践していて
それでもう全部均衡できているんというところで言って
もう最終的にこの経典で説法をいたっておいて
それが今瞑想するヴィパッサナー瞑想する誰の全ての人々の手本に
マニュアルに テキストになっているんです
それより立派なテキストはなし
そういうことですからね
ずっとべったしいなくちゃいけないっていうことじゃないんです
あの人にべったし一緒にいなくちゃいけないんだぞと思う人っていうのは
やっぱり聞く耳は持ってないんですね
なぜかというと 聞く耳持っちゃうとなかなか時間一緒にいられないんですよ
かなり大変なお仕事だからね
ずっと一緒にいるってことはもう耐えられないんです
会った 話しました 帰ったっていう感じで
どちらでも疲れますよ
むちゃくちゃ聞く能力はぐらいある人と喋ると
喋る人も結構疲れます
自分が考えたことないものを言うんだからね
聞く人にとっても結構大変な量なんですね
それでもうその時間終わったらもうそれでもう別れます
また自分が一人でデータ処理して全部できて
もう自分のようになってからまた会います
そういうことだからね
別にずっとずっとべったししている必要はないんです
それで一応智慧があるかないかっていうことは
我々は人の話を聞くかないかっていうことで
受信機を持っているかいないかということ
それからただ鵜呑みにすることは
話を聞いているわけじゃないんです
自分の責任で聞かなくちゃいけないんです
聞いたものは人の話じゃなくて
やがて自分自身の知識になることをよく覚えなくちゃいけないんです
だからうかつに聞くんじゃないんです
聞いたものは他人の知識じゃなくて
自分の知識になるんだから
それから自分の生き方はそれによって管理されますからね
そこを覚えていかなくちゃいけないんです
でないと 初めから拒絶反応とかなんとか言い訳入れるとかね
ことにはしますけどね
本当は大人にも理解できんほど難しいことでも
子供にでも理解させることはできますよ
でも条件はそいつは聞くか聞かないかという
ただそれだけです 聞こう
聞こうじゃないかということで成り立ちます